welcome to this episode of uxd where we
will talk about what user research is
and how you can use it to make better
products that users will actually want
to use i'm your host Nazmul Idris a
developer advocate passionate about
design and mobile and have a very
special guest with me today hi I'm rich
Fulcher I'm a designer and manager on
the Android team thank you for being
here thanks I'm rich from your personal
experience as a designer
why is user research important to
building great products well I've always
been able to benefit from user research
kind of throughout my career I feel that
it just helps bring me closer to the
people who are actually going to use the
products that I and my team's helped to
design and build and that's been true
for me at a big company like Google
where we have a large research staff
right it's also been true for much much
much smaller companies that I've been a
part of as well you know can thinking
back to my very earliest days as a
designer like my first class in was
called human-computer interaction back
in the day we've that very first class
we talked about you know that this is
the study of users in a context making
use of tools to perform tests to achieve
their goals so that kind of those five
important things users context tools
tasks goals are really what research
helps us speak to right you know as a
designer I have a lot of responsibility
in kind of defining the tool you know
what does your program look like how
does it work and I get a little bit of
influence over the task you know what
are the steps that I put you through or
how is it going to divide out into
different pieces research tells me a lot
about those other three areas as well so
it tells me about the users
you know a little bit more about who
they are it tells me about the context
that they use these products in and
that's both kind of environments and
just kind of state of mind and a lot of
different factors come into play there
and importantly it tells me about their
goals not just kind of get this thing
done but why do they want to get that
thing done what are they trying to
achieve in their lives right is the
reason for this product cool
so nas well what do you think of when
you hear the term user research like
what's the picture in your head so I
think about a lab in an office I think
about being part of a usability study
where other people watch me actually use
a product that's already been built to
see whether it makes sense to me or not
is that right it sounds like you're kind
of describing what that scene and
ghostbusters where dr. Venkman has the
students come into his lab in University
and doesn't ESP test and radio
electroshocks a few of them um I mean
but that is basically right I mean
that's one form of testing that's what
we'd call usability testing or in lab
usability studies and that's a very
common type and it's probably the one
that most people think of right as kind
of research when they think of it in a
canonical form and those focus on kind
of tools and tasks that we just talked
about so you know there's a tool there
where asking can the user use this tool
to complete the task we give the use of
the task when they step into the lab and
we just kind of see well did they do it
successfully if they did how long did it
take them to do it so time on task and
task completion great there's a lot more
that we can do in research than than
just that and it's not just testing
that's really important to kind of
remind people about the broader goal is
is bigger than just kind of validating
is this product working or not what you
want to get out of research is a richer
understanding about all of your users
you want to understand their perceptions
and their expectations you want to get
insight about them that you can apply
not just for this you know
thing that you're testing right here now
but you can apply to all the future
things you might build for your users I
mean the next version of the product or
a new product that kind of relates to
the same audience so now that's starting
to sound a little bit like market
research is that right
it's definitely related there's
definitely some overlap between those
disciplines certainly at kind of how
they conduct you know set up experiments
or do data analysis there's certain
certainly common elements there I think
about research market research is more
can focus on you know demographic or
marketing data and that's a little bit
more divorced from tasking goals but can
still speak to user in context it may be
things like purchasing behavior that tie
into that but user research I think is a
little bit more focused on the users
day-to-day behavior and what does user
want what do they need what are those
big you know capital G goals we talked
about earlier how did the different
contexts affect their ability to use a
product and you know if I'm if I've got
a phone and I'm just kind of using it
two-handed that's a different context
then if I have a latte and one-handed
and one-handed the phone and I'm also
running to catch a bus right it might be
the same product might be the same tasks
exact tool same tasks and goals even but
the context is going to make that a very
different experience for the user
exactly in fact we have an episode
dedicated just to context o definition
great cool so now those seem like really
big questions so how do you even ask
users those questions those are huge
questions and you're not going to be
able to answer all of them in in an in
lab study just right usability testing
that make sense so is this where the
expertise of user researchers come in
yeah absolutely you know on the surface
what a researcher does sometimes seems
simple you know just asking people
question and I can do that everybody can
do that exactly journalists its rightful
of course it's the same thing that
designers grapple with sometimes oh so
you you draw a picture of course
everybody can scribble like and I'm a
designer yeah I mean in both cases that
just kind of belies the rich
set of skills that an experienced
practitioner can bring to bear right and
for researchers they are particularly
expert at figuring out how to get
answers to difficult questions and so
interviewing just flat-out asking
somebody to question is is one technique
that they'll use but it is really just
one of many a lot of the techniques rely
on observation as opposed to direct
questioning and so that um you know it
may be going to users home into a
workplace it may be kind of bringing
them into a lab but not directly
prompting them to do certain things and
just seeing how they how they behave
it's like watching them in their native
habitat exactly there is an
anthropological asset to this that is
part of the discipline yep and
researchers complement that with a whole
bunch of skills you know one is in just
experimental design you know how do I
set up a study to find the answer to
this question how do I pick which
participants I should be bringing in to
answer this and I mitigate the bias you
know based on this artificial situation
I'm putting them in or based on which
users say I select analyze the data and
collect it right and then once I've
gotten those findings together how do I
actually bring those back to my team to
my designers to my engineers and really
convince them of the importance of these
findings those are all critical skills
that have a really good researcher can
bring to bear that makes sense sounds
like researchers are awesome and they
should be an integral part of every team
definitely um throughout my career which
is and yours I've been most proud of
products that I've shipped where design
and research have had a really strong
collaboration you know one just makes
the other better right
when you have a designer who really gets
research and is an active participant in
that process you know whether that's
they're helping to set up the experiment
or they're taking notes or capturing
video building a prototype now they just
get more and more of that immediate
information by being involved right
instead of just kind of waiting for the
findings of the report and seeing things
firsthand is always more powerful than
just kind of you know reading about it
after the fact
it puts a human context to it yeah and
it's it's definitely the kind of thing
that as a designer I will can it be in
working on something and I will think
back to Waiver particular experience I
write oh I remember when this user came
in and they did this thing right that
surprised me and I definitely dropped on
that cool and likewise a really great
researcher and will have a good
understanding of the design process and
they'll be really expert at kind of
thinking about well if this is the
process I know how to plug in here or
here or here and I know for each of
those opportunities what method is the
right one that I should employ cool so
now speaking of plugging into the
process where the ways you've seen
research conducted at different parts of
the product development lifecycle yeah
so this probably is a topic that
deserves its own episode but at a really
high level I think when you're when
you're starting out on a project you
want to go out and observe users kind of
in their natural environment right the
kind of things that you're looking for
here are to challenge the assumptions
that you may already have so you may
think users do this one thing but by
observing them you see ok they do do
that but they also do this other thing
or they do this thing in a slightly
different way than I thought they would
and so those kind of little surprising
insights can be really valuable and they
may even shift the direction of your
product as soon as you see those you can
also just kind of learn about what
already exists and so you can look at
other studies that you've done or that
are kind of published in the
you know academic literature and things
like that and you're asking this
question what's already been done but
really kind of the second-order question
is well how did that work out when
people did that so a little bit of that
is like competitive evaluation looking
at other applications that make sense so
is this like testing a competitor's
product before actually building your
own yeah I think a lot of us do that
already and people that are really
involved with technology we just kind of
do this casually as a user I mean we use
lots of different products and there's a
lot of input coming to us from just our
day-to-day behavior and we're thinking
about an area sometimes it's because
we've used something similar and or
maybe it's news we do something that
isn't satisfying for us and we know we
think we can do something interesting or
different in that space right this is
just kind of taking that natural
instinct to go and learn and making it a
little bit more rigorous that makes
sense
so now after you've gotten started and
you've chosen a direction or
interactively doing development how does
research come into play at that point
well I think research is best served
when it's just as iterative as the rest
of your development process so as early
as you can
you should get users to play with some
version of your product right and that
could be like a working prototype it
could be just a bunch of screenshots
that it may be a bit linked together it
could just be pieces of paper I've
definitely done all of these forms of
testing where you get to the paper you
get to kind of play the computer or
shuffle around the difference for
enzymes like that you're just trying to
learn like what's clicking for the user
what isn't clicking that it can kind of
come back to brand iterate iterate
iterate um you know this is a mantra you
look here probably a lot on this show
right you know make mistakes early so
you can get over them and make things
better in the next one exactly um you
can also just use this to address any
questions that kind of come up during
the course of building the product out
there's almost always some kind of
technique that you can use to help
answer a question even if I can't answer
it fully right um you know if you're
being forced to make a compromise on the
right yeah that never happens never yeah
I never heard of that actually nope
yep being able to draw upon research to
help you resolve how to make that how to
best make that set of trade-offs is
something that can be really helpful
yeah that's true so now as you get
closer to the end of this development
lifecycle on your release a product how
does research come into play here
I mean I'm is this where usability
testing comes in yeah it's definitely
kind of the most typical time that
you'll see in lab testing so you get the
working product there right um the kind
of things you're doing I think best
serving at that point or you're catching
kind of final bugs you're trying to kind
of identify am I really ready to launch
this thing right and it in particular
thing it identifies the types of bugs
that maybe your own team has just kind
of habituated itself to and kind of
overcome so it might be like problems
with the first use experience right as
I've been using to like every version of
the product you've worked on right
because you're biased obviously
absolutely you carry a ton of bias just
from your experience exactly um but you
should be kind of really apprehensive if
this is the first part of research that
you're doing at this point you know
changes that you make here are really
expensive in terms of time of resource
of possibly delaying your launch it's my
ear eating so important that's why it's
important and this is kind of don't just
wait till the end and don't just kind of
do validations right understand your
users much much earlier whenever
absolutely and then kind of when you're
at the end of course like launching
isn't really the end once you get the
product launched and you can observe how
live users you know use the product in
the wild you know not just how does
somebody use it two minutes after
they've been to introduced but you know
two days later two weeks two months
later right how is that changed what are
they what are they needed what do they
want what don't they use so you can look
at logs you can look at comments on the
Playstore right you can start at this
point thinking about well what's the
next release like what should what is
really really critical that it I need to
have in there because it's still missing
this for users what did I think was
going to be a big thing that I was going
to do more work on yeah now it's just
not important to users so maybe I pull
back from that exactly ya know because
it's not like your applications that
were finished like just because you've
launched a current version doesn't mean
you're going to not do upgrades and
doesn't mean there's not going to be
another version so it's never never the
end no no your work is never done
if you do it right it never ends that's
right exactly so what are some things
that designers in particular are looking
to get out of user research yeah I mean
for me it's always just great to hear
users kind of talk in their own language
and just kind of pay attention to the
particular vocabulary that a user makes
use of right when going through your
product or even separate from your
product when just doing their tasks
without it you can take that language
and you can borrow it and include into
the UI so that might be how you label an
action or what you choose to depict as
an icon or things like that it just
reduces the need for the user to
translate between their world and your
world yeah it may it reduces the
cognitive load and it makes it more
intuitive yes and I think that's a lot
of what intuitive to user means is it's
familiar to me either it's in the
language I understand or it's doing
things that I expect it to do based on
other context right I think that's what
intuition is for users exactly and you
know an example might be if the users
might use the word settings you might
want to use the word preference because
you think it's
kind of correct correct right some form
but if that's not the language the user
uses they have to do the translation
work to come to your product right you
can instead do the design work to bring
the product closer to what the user
understands and just kind of spare them
that effort and the last thing about
language is it can also be a bit of a
doorway into understanding the users
thought process so like if you talk to a
designer for more than like two or three
minutes you're going to hear the phrase
mental model and then I got it I think I
earned my badge you know we love to talk
about that all that really means is how
the user understands a process to work
in the world right and and I've seen
users construct both kind of vastly
simpler mental models in the real model
and you know much much much more
complicated things as well right
so I mean one example is for a mobile
device battery usage
I see users in research who engage in
all kinds of bizarre ritualistic
behaviors because they have a mental
model that says if I do these things I
will get more bad real
exactly so they swipe away recent
applications that they're not using how
do they you did both Thera now I've
talked to you that it's all over now
yeah or they put the device in airplane
mode and of course as they're doing all
of this they're driving the screen at
the highest brightness and keeping the
display active and actually possibly
being contrary to their goals because
the mental model doesn't match the real
model right and when there is that
mismatch like I get very excited as a
designer because that's a huge
opportunity know that make sense once I
see oh the user doesn't understand this
but if they could understand that they
would be
effective or their battery would last or
things like that
so those points of difference are really
interesting no definitely another
example this point is a refresh button
where folks that are not familiar with
push basically data being pushed
directly in a device might think that oh
there's no refresh buttons the data
they're seeing is stale right but
actually it's being updated in real time
and they just don't have an awareness of
that and then that can actually be
contrary to their sort of perception and
expectation from the software like it
feels like oh it's not performing as
well as it should because it doesn't
have a refresh button but in reality it
is performing well because it doesn't
have a refresh button yeah I mean we try
to be really careful as designers not to
kind of create the opportunity for false
rituals like by removing a refresh
button that doesn't do anything
exactly I'm hopefully moving a user away
from just kind of doing things to no
benefit or take an end result and
ideally I'm freeing up space to take a
meaningless action away and put a
meaningful action in its place because I
leave so much space for all of these
actions anyway at exactions I put the
less emphasis any one of them gets and
so yes this is you know very much what I
do on a daily basis it's fantastic so
how does user research help other folks
in a team because we've talked about the
benefit of designers what about benefits
to PM's product managers and also
engineers I think everything you do to
kind of better understand your your
users can help and I'm saying help
that's not the same as make your job
easier because sometimes it's very easy
to make an ignorant decision without
kind of knowledge of your users research
often will reveal that there's a lot
more variability in your audience and
then you've probably had in mind and
that can complicate some of your
decision making so this kind of like how
user research allows us to it's it's
kind of like we get to create our own
mental models off actual users and our
mental models might be overly simplistic
and and not actually match the reality
of our actual users that's exactly right
I mean the mental model we may have
maybe just kind of
with our own bias right in a lot of ways
that mental model of the who the user is
could just be well they're me exactly
because I know that person is and I want
to use this product right exactly I'm
obviously everyone is just like me um
that's not true at all right so by doing
research you can help release yourself
and release the whole the rest of the
team from those types of biases and
getting away from that kind of
monolithic model of the user is me you
know this is also helpful in kind of
making some of the debates about the
decision and those compromises less kind
of confrontational yes you're not
talking about I want this and you want
that exact it's our users are telling us
this we're advocates for the user
they're the stakeholders not us and that
doesn't mean the answer is obvious right
but at least we can kind of engage in
you know an honest debate about the
right way to try to satisfy right to a
goal that we agree on when you have
research you can talk about what you've
observed you can think back to that user
and tell that little anecdote growing up
well that might be true for you but I
saw this user and they did this thing
surprise me but they did right there was
a trick I learned from a colleague you
know long ago which is to be very
conscientious about that bias by just
repeating the word I when you're
speaking about your own opinion so if I
say well III think the product should
work this way right saying it three
times it makes it clear that which is
important especially for a designer
that's me talking not me speaking on
behalf of the user definitely you're
signaling to your colleagues that this
is your own personal personal opinion so
they can treat it with whatever bias I
mean look at it with bias that's built
into that statement yeah and I think
it's helpful for others but it's also
just helpful for me because I that
ritual that I have already doing III is
there to remind me that wow there's what
I'm thinking not what
I've shown me from research now that
makes sense so that's all the time we
have for this episode I know thank you
so much for being here it um we will do
many more episodes on the topic of user
research very soon great well thanks for
having me it's been a pleasure
absolutely and if you haven't already
please be sure to join your UX community
on Google+ it's a place where you can
continue this discussion and you can
meet others who are just as passionate
about UX as you are thank you very much
and have a great day goodbye